how's it going bros my name is P a lot
of people come on it was kind of obvious
libros wanted me to continue playing
this and I got a lot of you I don't know
who I'm gonna give credit for this but
apparently there's a secret if you hit
one of these blocks and the bank round
you can do I'll just kind of [ __ ] I
think it's this one behind I just had to
hit it no I didn't gay
wait did I get it I quit it wow that's a
fail let's do that again
alright let's do that again come on bro
you can do yep huh come on
why is he why are you doing this there
we go no I didn't give me here yeah we
go alright here we go
so we have this poor little sucker
you're my [ __ ] right now you don't know
yet but you're my [ __ ] huh you think
you're tough huh
you think you're tough you want to get
up no no no you don't get up no your
boss out now any good now bad
no now I'm so sensitive ouch ouch ouch
fitting ouch ouch now this is the worst
date ever
to get stuck oh man please make it stop
thank God
[Music]
you're my [ __ ] you're my [ __ ] oh no
I'm not my bad again pity it's a
hemorrhoid Oh God why are you doing this
to me why did I ever do to you
look I'm balancing on my butt look are
you happy I'm sorry fella
oh man you bros have to try it
Wow if I ever feel bad or anything I'll
get it okay let's make it fall out now
beat it don't make me fall up now please
I do anything that can still kill now
all right I'll just let him fall for
eternity anyway I just had to try that
out can we do a regular one what did I
not do the last time for computers why
would you play only computer that make
no sense you verse 3 yeah that's right
okay
I am the blue one I think okay you [ __ ]
is going down are they're all teaming up
on me are you suck no I got last all
right this ain't over yet [ __ ] no
they're not thank you why I hate you
look at that it's the last month
standing here I go in for the green one
you're my [ __ ] you're gonna die damn it
hey
yeah oh this is not a good spot for me
I'll brief you cut it's that anyway
hey let's turn around and go for these
guys yeah okay Sidious I'm serious
hello the green guy doing it's gonna
fall out I want to make a fall out come
on green guy
you did okay yes green guy oh come on
get up buddy how you skinned up now my
green guy must do something
yes oh okay you're going down sucker
okay don't fall down don't fall down on
the green baize done - yes and the white
one
alright let's do one more I would
actually try to win I'm gonna get you
guys I hate you I think it's impossible
to win May has three rows you're not my
brows now Oh second now that bad I'll go
with second all right one more time
I'm going for the brown one you did you
did I could actually win this rent
you're going down yeah okay that's
enough for that one I want to try
another one that yeah alright I don't
know if I played on lines before but
let's try allies me versus computer
let's oh look at these I don't even know
what's going on but you've gone down
white guy you're going down Oh are we
walking on ice or something let's go for
this what yeah no ah oh
the ground is ice I get it now oh man oh
I'm gonna [ __ ] okay get up look at oh
come on I'm stuck ah boys come down with
me oh you [ __ ]
I just love the movement in this game
all right hey let me try that again
our against computers I doubt it'll work
now it's just me and him
okay all right all right let's do this
I'm coming I'm coming for you bro
no way come at me bro come at me brah
come at me bro come at me bro I'm coming
for you bro come at me bro I'm coming
for you bro
come at me bro oh it would have been
awesome even fell down there come on get
up
I'm waiting for you bro I'm waiting up
shut up all right let's do what what man
they were full sighing it's why I'm
gonna make this what's he doing the
floor isn't cracking anymore but get off
me get up this is my ice hey don't fill
out the tiniest hole in this oh man
let's try another one
all right let's try the house I don't
even know anymore I guess three
computers and I got a six minute anyway
hey what's going on here bro what are we
fighting if I have to fight
what am i doing all right yeah they can
find out here why don't you lose house
really wait why did I lose I didn't do
anything
he's pushing me to the side I'm I fall
out that's ridiculous
enough me it's my house I feel down
laughs I should have won that one white
one what you doing
let's [ __ ] this house up huh Oh that'd
be awesome
let's make them travel all right come on
just push this I did nothing
how did a houseful of hey I want to try
a one more all right one more Bros one
freakin more I want to try fall ooh good
okay I got my eyes on you mr. Brown well
I guess that's hard less I'll try that
again what do you do it back and try
again
all right one more you have three
computers oh oh okay okay let's see what
the brown one [ __ ] up again it was
hilarious
Green Alana's gonna give it I just wait
here until they fall down yeah all right
that was somewhat or dreams hope you
bros enjoyed like a favorite college if
you did it really helps me out a lot and
subscribe if you haven't even coming
both today and that's pretty much it
[Music]